m
je
mais bonjour diagonale donc la leçon
avec et loire blanchon jour et loi
bonjour stephen bonjour à tous ami
internaute qui apprenaient les échecs
donc aujourd'hui on va voir un thème
très important du jeu d'échecs après
avoir vu les finales on va rentrer dans
des choses plus générale et on va voir
aujourd'hui un thème qui est très
important oui telle tactique très
important le premier qu'on a déjà vu
c'était c'était le thème de la tacc
double dit plus vulgairement la
fourchette
et bien aujourd'hui nous allons voir un
nouveau grand am tactique et donc le
clouage le clouage thème très connu et
très utile et en fait hyper fréquents
dans les parties d'échecs 1 pourquoi le
clouage on enfonce le clou dans une
planche alors c'est pratiquement ça
puisque en fait on va prendre une pièce
et faire en fait on va là cloud et c'est
à dire qu'on va fixer dans la position
où elle est simplement en menaçant une
pièce donc d'une valeur plus élevée
c'est on va empêcher cette pièce de ceux
de s'enlever de la case où elle se
trouve
puisque sinon elle mettrait aux prises
une pièce qui aurait une valeur énorme
oubli par exemple le roi qui lui a une
valeur maximale
alors voila si c'est le roi qui est
derrière la pièce cloud et cette pièce
est effectivement c'est un clouage
absolue la pièce ne peut plus bouger
sinon elles mettraient leur emprise ce
n'est carrément plus un coup légal donc
le clouage bon je pense que je pense que
le mieux c'est de voir quelques exemples
qui seront bien plus explicite que des
mots dans le vent alors en voyant le
premier exemple donc que tu nous a
concocté oui alors exemple très simple
donc c'est une position roi et tour
contre roy est fou donc cette position
est nul
en principe c'est à dire que si les
blancs jouent amène le roi donc le plan
pour faire nul c'est d'amener le roi sur
la case de la couleur opposée aux fous
il est ensuite il ya plus de solutions
pour le camp qui est roi et tour pour
gagner cette partie d'accord mais pour
arriver à cette position évidemment faux
pas qui est des deux pièges
intermédiaire il faut voilà il faut
éviter les pièges et il faut surtout ne
pas perdre le fou puisque sinon
effectivement on va perdre la partie
donc ici c'est au noir de jouer s'il est
blanc joue un coup ils vont
vraisemblablement prendre le roi et
l'amener sur la case eux deux et là ce
sera une partie tout simplement nul donc
ici le coup gagnant est celui là parce
que c'était donc au moins de jouer
voyant que les noirs jouent tour à eux
deux et donc là on est dans un exemple
de clouage voilà puisque le fou
s'il devait partir s'il venait à bouger
il mettrait directement le roi emprise
ce qui n'est pas possible il n'est pas
possible puisque c'est illégal donc de
fou le fou est effectivement trouvé sur
la planche il peut plus bouger
voilà le faut être complètement cloud et
ne peut plus bouger que reste-t-il comme
coup aux blancs il ne reste que les
coups droits malheureusement dans cette
position un obligé de jouer le roi donc
le fou ne peut pas bouger
donc on va bouger droit mais on ne peut
pas aller défendre le fou puisque le fou
est trop loin le roi se déplace que
d'une case à la fois on peut le rappeler
donc le roi vient ici sur la case 17
donc on des clous le fou puisque
maintenant il peut bouger où il veut
mais heureusement ce vaisselle jouets
voilà c'est trop tard et noir hamas est
ici donc gain facile
on l'a déjà vu dans diagonale la leçon
avec roy et tour contre roy ont gagné
très facilement
oui d'ailleurs on vous invite à revoir
7,7 cette leçon si vous l'avez pas vu
qu'une comment gagner avec troyes et
tours
c'est ce qui permet de mater rapidement
de cette position alors reprenons donc
ce que l'on a vu c'est que dans la
position de départ on a fait un clouage
avec une tour c'est la tour qui est venu
sur cette case là donc c'est un clouage
totalement sur une colonne haute ça
aurait aussi pu être sur une rangée donc
la tour peut faire des clous âge comme
ça en structure des colonnes en tout cas
pour faire un creux si je comprends bien
il faut une pièce à longue portée c'est
une tour ou alors éventuellement un fou
une perf le wyndham en tout cas un
cavalier ne peut pas faire de clouage
oui parce que lui il a une courte portée
il saute par dessus donc il est gêné par
un excellent les pièces lecavalier ne
peut pas faire de cloche puisqu'il ne
contrôle kappa tau casse qui suivent
donc tout simplement il n'y a pas de ya
pas de problème avec contrôle toujours
les cas sur lesquels il peut aller de
toute façon que les cases sur lesquels
il peut lire et aucune autre donc tout
simplement
tout simplement pas tous âges avec le
cavalier exemple à suivre donc
ici nous avons deux fous donc là on va
voir le thème du cloud j'avais donc
thème du clown avec le fou de fond un
roi contre eux roy et cavani alors une
fois de plus si c'est au noir de jouer
ils vont ramener leurs cavaliers près du
roi et il y a une position défensive
avec trois cavaliers contre euro et de
fou c'est difficile à défendre mais on
peut on peut je crois y arriver cette
finale a été réfutée récemment par ken
thompson avec son cd sur les finales à
moins de cinq pièces
je pense que la nouvelle évaluation est
nulle et qu'avant considéré que c'était
perdant donc affaire à suivre
en tout cas ici les blancs évidemment
savent qu'avec deux fous contre roye ils
vont gagner facilement
ça c'est très simple c'est un peu comme
le mat avec les deux tours sauf que ça
se passe sur les gones avaient tout
simplement oui donc de fou ça gagne donc
ici un objectif très simple prendre le
cavalier et pour cela nous allons une
fois de plus faire appel au cloud âge
avec fou c'est un an b2 clouage sur la
bande d donald donc al kamali peut pas
bouger sous peine de mettre son endroit
un échec
donc il est encore une fois que l'eau et
sur sa planche comme tout à l'heure nous
voilà complètement cloud est ici laura
noir doit à bouger donc il a d'occase
possible laquelle j'essaie tout les
cases achète puisque la case donc
justement la case à 15h ça a été quand
les progrès dans le trajet cet objet 8
donc mettons qu'il vienne sur j'évite de
toute façon ça ne change pas grand chose
au coup suivant on prend le cavalier et
on arrive dans notre fameuse finale de
fouet roi contre roy et ça tout
simplement ça gagne de manière assez de
technique
donc si on ramène les diagonales vers un
coin en fait on ramène le roi vert en
coin avec les fous et ça suffit pour
mater avec l'aide du roi blanc
évidemment failli à leurs oiseaux et
d'adhérents participent à cette action
qui est d'amener le roi noir faire un
coin puisque s'il n'est pas là s'il
n'est pas dans l'action c'est impossible
de lier à mener car on ne contrôle pas
assez de cases avec juste deux fous donc
voilà exemple tout simple un clouage
avec un fou position de départ quand le
cavalier veut revenir si cette oblongue
jouer donc on fait le clouage mais c'est
une arme très important et nous plonge à
le clash c'est très très important mon
lacet dépression très simple c'est juste
pour expliquer ce qui se passe
maintenant on va voir des thèmes
plus compliqué où le clouage est un peu
plus complexe alors nouvel exemple donc
la finale retour contre roy et cavaliers
nuls ça y est autorisée les galeries
dans la majorité des cas bien entendu
évidemment s'il est blanc arrive à
prendre le cavalier ils vont gagner
alors ici qu'est ce qui se passe le
cavalier est cloué il est cloué mais
cependant il fait quand même échec
puisque les pièces cloud et qu'elle soit
loué sur n'importe quoi fera quand même
jalonnera blanc est sous la menace du
cavalier de laurent blanc serait pris en
main le roi noir donc voilà c'est
interdit donc le roi plan est en échec
ici on se demande ce qui peut se passer
pour les noirs puisqu'ils ont simplement
roi et cavaliers qui sont proches c'est
à dire qu'en principe le cavalier va pas
se faire enfermer lequel elle devrait
pas se faire prendre et si on arrive à
stabiliser la position à croas cavaliers
la partie est nul mais le cavalier avec
l'ol cependant il est défendu
et donc quand l'instant a priori pas de
problème oui alors les blancs toile fut
un coup droit et très naturellement ils
viennent sur la case des 5
donc ça attaque une nouvelle fois
cavalier donc le cavalier se retrouvent
attaqué deux fois et il est toujours
incapable de bouger
puisqu'il ya le roi derrière et il est
toujours floue et oui donc ça va être
les noirs vont être obligés de jouer le
roi et le cavalier mettre sous la prise
de deux de deux ennemis contre seuls
défenseurs
voilà exactement donc par exemple après
roy f7 tout reprend cavaliers ici le roi
ne peut pas reprendre la tour bien
entendu puisque celle ci est défendue
par le roi blanc donc pas de problème
pour les blancs ici la finale retour
contre roye qui gagne donc une fois de
plus le thème du clonage en action il
semblerait que les noirs tiennent
malheureusement leur public louer ses
traits
il faut intervenir très vite par exemple
si les blancs au premier coup d'oeil
joue parfois des cinq mayroy c4 c'est
une grosse faute puisque ben là le roi
sort du cloud âge
et là c'est terminé et maintenant c'est
nul à moins que les noirs fasse exprès
de se remettre un clouage mais a priori
peuvent l'éviter
voilà c'est dire que si on joue au roi
des cinq maintenant évidemment le
cavalier va bouger
n'étant plus cloud et il peut venir
angers 5 par exemple est ici c'est une
finale nul droit à cavaler contre au
retour c'est nul sans problème donc le
clouage est une arme très volatile qu'il
faut exploiter au plus vite
c'est à dire que un coût plus tard très
bien la pièce ne plus être cloué ou peut
être parti ou enfin c'est vraiment très
très ponctuel ça demande une
intervention très rapide dont trois des
cinq ici le bon coup clouage attaqué
deux fois aurait fait et maintenant on
prend le cavalier c'était inévitable est
tout simplement nous gagnons le cavalier
et la partie positions suivantes nos
plats bilan matériel
touré fou contre tours et cavaliers donc
a priori ça devrait être nulle
a priori ça devrait être nul bien
entendu puisque même touré fou contre
tours c'est encore ils sont nuls mais on
voit que le roi noir
il est un peu il est un petit peu
enfermé déjà il est assez mal assez mal
n'a pas trop de cases autre remarque il
ya des rayons x
ça c'est très important cette notion de
rayons x qui va un peu de pair avec le
clouage qui va de pair avec à dire que
la tour peut attaquer fait un tacle le
roi indirectement parce qu'il n'ya de
pied sur son chemin mais elle est là
elle a une action potentiel en tout cas
oui tout à fait effectivement si ça
avait été un pion à la place du fou ici
un pion sur la case h4 à la place des
fouilles aurait pas eu de rayons x
puisque la méfiance que le footeux
sortir et donc réactivé la tour voilà le
fou le cavalier ou n'importe quelle
pièce en fait peut changer de colonnes
alors qu'un pion ne peut pas changer de
colonne c'est pour ça qu'on commence à
avoir des idées dans cette position il
ya un cavalier noir en f7 un fond blanc
h4 ces deux pièces que donc si on les
enlever il y aurait la tour qui
viendrait donner un échec et mat
donc ça ça donne effectivement des idées
la tour noire pour l'instant ne sert pas
à grand chose
c'est aux blindes jouer il est une
solution très simple qui exploite le
thème du cloud âge dans cette position
d'accord donc c'est le coup il faut
bouger le fou surnom il faut bouger le
fou effectivement c'est les les noirs
veulent quand même joué pour le mans
tours à cet échec
donc il faut empêcher ça il faut
empêcher ça il faut empêcher tout tout
échec venant des noirs ont fait nous
mêmes un échec avec fo et 6 voilà faut
aussi ce qui donc est échec échec et mat
et matt puisque le cavalier ne peut pas
prendre le fou et oui il lui dit si la
prise du cavalier mais il est toujours
cloué voilà il est toujours floue et
enfin il est nourri dès à présent cloué
à présent que vous dire que le fou est
en partie de cette diagonale on veut
dire une kia vallier je voulais dire
toujours par rapport aux exemples
précédents
c'était évidemment mais alors
effectivement donc là il ya un échec et
mat alors qu'on a l'impression que l'on
pourrait prendre la pièce qui fait échec
oui mais non alors pourquoi ces échecs
et mat évidemment le roi est attaqué et
où comme vous nous permet de sauver de
sauver les chèques voilà toutes les
cases autour du roi sont contrôlées soit
par le roi blanc soif par le fond blanc
soit le cavalier noir qui prend une case
donc ici on peut rien interposés entre
le roi est fou on ne peut pas bouger le
roy on ne peut pas prendre le fou ça
fait trois éléments et donc c'est matt
tout simplement et bonnes manières
devait d'empêcher les fins de se
retrouver dans une position ne serait
pas un échec
donc ici c'est une fois de plus un
clouage absolue puisque le cavalier ne
peut absolument pas bouger
simplement parce qu'il mettrait le roi
emprise ça c'est interdit par les règles
tout simplement c'est interdit par les
règles de john woo est tout à fait
nouvelle nouvel exemple qui est donc
cette fois ci un exemple positionnelle
du milieu de partie donc là on va un
petit peu vous mettre au parfum des des
idées de l'ouverture donc c'est une
première dans une première dans des
godets de la leçon on va on va voir un
petit peu donc d4
le coût des deux décades je pense que
c'est la première fois qu'on le voit ici
puisque normalement vous montrent plutôt
des ouvertures issus du coup eu 2 4 donc
d2 d4
l'idée c'est de prendre de l'espace côté
gauche de l'échiquier
l'idée générale du coût des quatre et de
jouer le petit rouquin toujours on va
les rockets de ce côté là bon des deux
des quatre ça se commentera plus tard
cavani m6 et tout de suite on installe
un duo de pions au centre avec le coup
c'est de ses cadres donc là on installe
d'options au centre donc ça contrôle
déjà quatre belles cases le plan des
blancs c'est de sortir le cavalier en f3
puis le fou
pour ensuite avancé le pion eux sortir
le deuxième fou et faire le petit rock
ça c'est un plan très très très très
classique les noirs jouent aussi ce donc
les noirs veulent eux rock est assez
rapidement ce qui est tout à fait normal
et ce qui se comprend très bien donc eu
six l'idée peut être de sortir le fou
soit 11,7 soit en b 4 2 possibilités et
après qu'est et ses trois fous b4 et ici
les noirs font une stratégie élaborée
puisque donc ils font un clouage sur ce
cavalier en c3
donc le cas il ne peut pas bouger et
l'idée est de prendre le contrôle des
cases blanches en rouge ici puisque ce
cavalier donc ne bouge plus le cavalier
noir lui est très efficace peut aller
sur les deux cases à venir
ces deux coups b6 celui du couffo
bessette tout ça donc l on peut
commenter encore quelques coups dans
cette ouverture ninkovic comme on
l'appelle ses limites en inuit est
caractéristique est caractérisée par don
parce clouage fou des quatre web qui
donc en pêche que cavalier de contrôler
les cases blanches au centre et le but
de secouer fait voilà c'est de contrôler
ces cases blanches
c'est un coup très critique très
important la menace directe et de jouer
probablement fou prend cavaliers qui
doublerait les pions des blancs donc ça
c'est un autre principe
voyons maintenant après dame ses 2,11
jouber 6 après cavaliers f3 on joue faux
bessette
donc là on est vraiment dans la logique
à se battre pour ses cases blanches
ici un coût possible c'est le coup j'ai
3 et maintenant je pense que le bon coup
pour les noirs dans cette position c'est
de profiter tout de suite du cloud âge
par cavalli f6 en quatre alors qu'est ce
qui se passe le cavaliere e4 est attaqué
deux fois et par le cavalier blanc et
par la dame blanche
mais évidemment le cavalier en c3 ne
peut pas bouger ne peut pas bouger car
il est cloué donc c'est un leurre donc
le cavalier ou 4 n'est pas en prison
peut très bien profiter du cloud âge
pour prendre le centre et ça c'est un
des événements
un des
et une des idées importantes de
l'ouverture pour le centre toujours donc
ici on profite du cloud âge c'est un
stratagème qui va nous servir à prendre
possession du centre
donc voilà des idées concrètes du
clonage de l'ouverture on va revoir ses
premiers coups de la défense ninkovic
donc des deux des quatre cavaliers f6
tout de suite on prend le contrôle des
d'occase c4 les blancs eux font un
quatuor de pions en fait un quatuor de
case control et en rouge avec un duo de
pion aux six donc libère le fou hiver le
fou comme les c3 contrôle le centre en
maintenant les blancs sont prêts à jouer
eux deux quatre six ont le regret si on
leur permettait de jouer sa fougue et 4
évite tout de suite aux cadres grâce au
clonage dame ces deux on veut rejouer
aux 4 b 6 alors sur quatre et des ventes
très compliqué à base de d5
mais finalement les noirs sont mieux
qu'elles vivent trois fous 17 g iii et
maintenant profite complètement du cloud
âge par le coup cavalière 624 ensuite on
va doubler les pions des blancs et ainsi
de suite
donc ici avantage noir enfin avantage
noir façon de parler les noirs utilise
un clouage pour égaliser la position
très probablement un nouvel exemple
alors ici plus épuré plus épurée mais
d'accord donc là alors là c'est une
position ben priori ou les noirs un
avantage alors les noirs un avantage
c'est gagnant pour les noirs dames
contre tours ça gagne dans pratiquement
tous les cas il ya cependant des
exceptions
alors ici que remarque-t-on première
remarque c'est que les bleus ont très
très chaud parce qu'il ya des menaces de
maths dans tous les coins
la menace est très simplement d'un bep 2
échec est l'échec et mat ou dmp est un
échec et mat nous qu'il ya beaucoup de
menaces
à noter que tours b 4 n'est pas une
solution
le coup tours b 4 n'est pas une solution
pourquoi parce que dans le final droit
et dames contre roi et où et quand cette
eau conquis à la dame de jouer et bien
c'est toujours gagnant c'est une règle
c'est une halte s'est produit à être
même tout simplement une dame ses trois
échecs dans la roue de suite bien
d'autrui 2009 cheikh
en tout cas la finale
la finale dames contre troyes et tours
gagne à tous les coups on gagne à tous
les coups tout simplement donc tort des
cadres mais ces trois chaque rame à cela
tous là c'est une fourchette l'attaquent
double c'est ce qu'on a vu la dernière
fois donc tourné quatre n'est pas une
bonne option
en revanche on peut se dire bien
regardons regardons bien là on voit que
la dame noire contrôler toutes les cases
autour du roi je n'ai donc à donner ma
tour et c'est nul
donc je vais jouer autour d un échec oui
parce que parce que si une fois que la
torah disparu ce serait pas une fois que
la torah disparu ses pattes dans la
sueur roi prend tour
eh bien nous y sommes ici ses pattes
c'est aux blancs de jouer mais ils ne
peuvent pas jouer donc puisque la dame
noire contrôler toutes les cases premier
noir peuvent sont pas obligés de prendre
un vécu au roi alors voilà ça c'est un
peu le problème du coup c'est que
justement c'est la dame qui vient
ramasser cette tour et là nous avons un
gros problème avec les blancs parce
qu'on peut jouer puisque maintenant nous
pouvons jouer on peut jouer 3 à 2 sur
quoi les noirs évidemment ne se prive
pas de damas quatre échecs et 1 de damas
quatre échecs et mat
donc ici reprendre la position de départ
puisqu'on est un petit peu vite dans
cette position là on voit deux
possibilités on se dit d'abord j'ai
envie de parler le mat dont faisait que
la tourbe et 4 mais ça marche pas parce
que dams et trois échecs une perle
ampera tour tombé 4 adams et trois
chèques et on perd la tour donc on ne se
dit pas tomber caton ce pas ensuite on
finit par se dire et bien tiens je suis
pas tu donc je vais donner ma tour donc
tour d un échec pour donner à tour il
faut faire un échec
oui mais ici problème il ne prend pas
avec le roi qui donnerait un pâtes mais
avec la dame hélas rien savoir bien
tenté quand même c'est bien tenté de
laisser dire qu'il faut avoir ce genre
d'idées dans les positions qu'ils sont
désespérés
la pression du début est désespérée
madame contre le retour on sait que ces
perdants
il faut donc chercher des solutions
alors qu'à l'est est ce qu'il ya une
solution
sk une semaine un voire deux
possibilités qui marchent pas voilà il
ya une autre possibilité qui serait de
jouer par exemple tour d2 mais puisque
sur roy prend ou sur dame prend cette
fois y'a pas tu vois la saisir comme
l'atout emprise mais elle n'est pas
prenable puisque dans les deux cas il y
aurait pattes mais si gossip tellement
c'est une bonne idée
c'est une c'est une bonne idée est une
idée en tout cas il y aurait des trois
chaînes en bien
whitacre nommé cheikh ayman salaires
plus rapide autant pour moi
enfin autant pour tout de suite
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux donc
quand on n'est pas obligé ccxr on
rappelle qu'aux échecs ça permet de
revoir causer chez qu'on n'est jamais
obligé de prendre un c'est quand même
c'est quand même c'est pour ça que c'est
merveilleux on donne la tour
l'impression que les preneurs de tous
les côtés et si on la prend ses impacts
c'est donc une partie nulle une rampe
rendre par la tour on préfère asséné le
mac directement
effectivement c'est mieux donc ici il y
à une solution
il ya une solution il faut un empêcher
la dame de no matter au coup d'après
donc là on pense quand même à une
solution précise pour empêcher la dame
devenir no matter on a le choix entre
deux possibilités soit on prend la dame
en fait être aux possibilités sont prend
la dame ici on ne peut pas se contrôler
les cazoulins faire échec
soit on contrôle les cas cela me fait un
chèque soit on fait un échec c'est ce
qu'on a vu son nom fait un échec qu il
soit en cloud la dame soit en cloud la
dame voilà ça fait beaucoup de possibles
candidats au sirop thème du cloud et
c'est peut-être ça l'idée c'est sous le
thème du cloche c'est peut-être ça
l'idée alors tout à fait donc ici on a
vu déjà les échecs on a vu la protection
des cases on a vu qu'on ne pouvait pas
pour la dame donc on se dit finalement
évincé peut-être le clouage et on arrive
à trouver ce coup tour des quatre ans et
4 cloud la dame alors là les noirs n'ont
que quatre coups possibles soit ils
bougent le roi ça fait beaucoup mais ce
cas là on prend la dame et sylis et
parties nulles dans ce cas là on prend
la dame et ses parties nulles soit il
bouge la dame mais là elle ne peut pas
aller où elle veut la dame puisque si
elle vient sur la case b1 la cl mais
très loin aux prises oui donc ça ce
n'est pas possible c'est interdit alors
qu'il faut prendre un tour il faut pour
la tour elle peut aussi aller sur
laquelle ces trois celle-là droit
puisque ça ne sortirait pas du clonage
ouais mais alors dans ce cas là on prend
la dame et on gagne on pour la dame
longueuil donc ça c'est une grosse faute
donc ici la dame doit prendre la tour
voilà et là qu'est ce qu'on voit et bien
drame
il s'agit d'un pattes donc c'est un
super sacrifice de tours en fait c'est
super sacrifice de tours c'est un
superbe ce fils de tours c'est là le roi
blanc n'a plus de gaz c'est fini dans
cette position-là tour c4 la dame est
cloué on va prendre la dame
il faut que la dame rouge qu'elle prenne
la tour et quand elle prend la tour et
c'est le drame
c'est un pat
donc ici la position de départ était
clairement perdante rodamco 3 tout ça
gagne à chaque fois pour la dame
sauf que nous avons bénéficié d'un coup
magique qui part du cloud âge et qui
nous permet de faire nul grâce au thème
du pat et du cloud et donc le thème
n'est pas qu'on a déjà vu aussi
précédemment
oui ils n'ont mené sur numéro deux de la
donc on a bien même parler de ce thème
là donc la tour c 4 pas mal tout la dame
et quand la dame prend il ya pas tu sais
c'est super beau coup c'est un superbe
coup et ça explose parfaitement à même
le sol c'est le seul c'est le seul coup
qui fait du silicium guitry finul oui
tous les autres coûts devenu un math
rapide
voilà pour cet exemple est maintenant on
va passer au plus bel exemple de la
soirée en fin de la matinée puisque nous
sommes le matin c'est un math tout à
fait exceptionnel c'est le mat de le
gall le match de le gall qui dit donc à
ne pas confondre avec le café à ne pas
confondre avec le café oui parce que je
crois que c'est un joueur dans c'est un
match qui est connu depuis très
longtemps déjà oui c'est un match qui
est connu depuis le
je pense que 19ème siècle le gall était
un professeur de mathématiques qui était
assez doué pour les échecs et qui a
trouvé ce superbe maths qui ce super
veut maths alors voyons voyons ce
superbe match donc on part de la
position de départ vous la connaissez il
ya cette pièce pour tout le monde
un roi chacun des pièces dans tous les
sens et 8 pions alors au début principe
un prendre le centre eu quatre réponses
des noirs eux sainte
donc là ici c'est une partie modèle côté
blanc principe de développer ces pièces
cavaliers f3 très logique attaque en
même temps le pion en 5 17 des six
teintes du c'est jouable aussi tout à
fait jouable
c'est ce qu'on appelle la défense
philidor tout à fait classique du nom du
fameux grand maître les fameux champion
du monde de l'époque un feuilleton peut
dire le joueur qui dominait le monde à
l'époque louise andrée danican philidor
compositeur de musique aussi très grand
joueur d'échecs
donc si c'est lui qui a dit que les
pions sont l'âme du jeu d'échecs
oui tout à fait finie d'or est connu et
reconnu pour son talent d'écrivain
échiquéen il a apporté énormément au jeu
d'échecs
c'était un d un des précurseurs de
justement du jeu de pions c'est lui qui
a qui a fait toutes les chaînes de pions
et ici il est bien dans son bien dans
son principe puisqu'il arrive à faire
une chaîne d'options qui se tient sur 4
noir donc ici défense philidor côté noir
fou c4 alors là tout de suite on
commence à faire des on sort encore une
caisse et on vise le pion à vii
ça c'est toujours une bonne chose de
devises espion dans l'ouverture puisque
ces options n'est défendue que par le
roi donc ça doit toujours y des femmes
lascives de combinaisons et attaques
diverses donc les noirs ici font une
faute
ils ont peur un petit peu ils ont très
peur de ce coup cavaliers étrangers 5
wickets avril à gré attaqué le pion à
vii - évidemment le cavalier ne peut pas
égaler encore mais ils veulent se
prémunir contre ça ils jouent ce qu'on
appelle les oreilles d'âne c'est à dire
le coût h 7 h si ce qui est une sorte de
ride and un coût qui ne sert à pas
grand-chose qui normalement
donc n'est pas bon puisque ça ne
développent pas de pièce ça n'aide pas à
contrôler centre et c'est donc très
logiquement une faute mais comment faire
pour l'exploiter on peut encore se le
demande et donc les blancs continuent
avec un coût très très logique joue le
coup kelly b en c3 donc continuer à
développer leurs pièces alors là on voit
que les pièces sont sur les meilleures
positions les deux cavaliers sur les
cases sont sur leur meilleure position
ici sur les classes vertes chiot on voit
un croisement superbe dos et deux
cavaliers qui contrôlent donc les quatre
cases centrale donc ici les blancs ont
mis leurs pièces sur les meilleures
positions puisque le fou en c4 est
également bien placé puisqu'il vise
directement la pression des rois noirs
et les blancs sont prêts à croquer alors
que les normes toujours pas ressenti de
pièces les noirs dont toujours pas
sortie de pièces donc ici avantage blanc
c'est au noir de jouer il faudrait jouer
calé j'ai 8 ans et 6 avec une position
évidemment inférieurs puisqu'on a sorti
on n'a pas sorti assez de pièces mais
les noirs font une faute et joue fou
s'est vite
angers 4 qui effectue un clouage
stéphane et qu'elle arbore donc en fait
puisque ces rames pêche le cavalier de
bouger puisque s'il bouge on perdrait la
dame si lecavalier bouche on perd la
dame donc c'est un clouage relatif si
pas un clown absolue parce que les
règles permettent de le faire on peut en
droit de sacrifier sa dame si on veut si
c'était le roi on pourrait pas si
c'était le roi pourrait pas nous qui
alors qu'ici on peut simplifier lavables
effectivement ça nous donne une idée ça
pourrait donner l'idée de jouer par
exemple qufu confions à vii qui ont
recettes après roy prend on peut se dire
maintenant je joue cavalier f 3.5 avec
ça ce n'est qu'un des moyens de contrer
clouage relatif c'est à dire que la
pièce qui est cloué s'en va en attaquant
le roi c'était en faisant échec ce qui
nous permet nous de prendre la pièce qui
nous clouer ce qui fait en fait une
prise à à la découverte
c'est ça c'est une prise à la découverte
en fait on est rodé on découvre
finalement découvre la pièce qui est
clos et on la découvre mais en faisant
un échec donc on est obligé de parer les
chèques et après on peut voilà on
comprendre la pièce
malheureusement on a donné une pièce est
là alors
un des deux fait ce qu'on a donné
d'abord le fou sur la case afsset qui a
été pris par le roi on a donné ensuite
le cavalier donc on a donné deux pièces
pour apprendre une donc c'est pas très
bon non c'est une très mauvaise
opération puisque n'oublions pas qu'au
échec quand même le matériel a une
importance capitale
quand on dit le matériel c'est à dire
que une pièce de plus dans une partie
d'échecs
ça devrait vous amener vos gains
d'ailleurs on l'avait vu un pion doit
suffire donc c'est une bonne idée mais
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas l'idée
qu'il faut avoir c'est une bonne idée
qui ne marche pas ici il ya bien plus
fort il ya ce fameux matt de légal alors
là c'est un superbe coup cavaliers f3
prend pion aux 5 donnes adam dunn la
dame est alors alors on pourrait prendre
le cavalier parce que lecavalier temps
prise on peut s qui se passe dans le
monde la maladie alors prise du cavalier
ici il y aurait d'un prof ou tout
simplement avec gaines de pions avec un
pion très simplement et donc on l'a vu
justement sur ces fameuses émission un
pion suffit la finale répond contreras
toutes les finales où un pion suffi pour
gagner ici maintenant le plan des blancs
c'est d'échanger toutes les pièces
d'arriver dans une finale avec un point
de plus et de la gagner parce qu'on sait
le faire et à si on revoit des gones à
la leçon consacrée aux finales de piau
on peut s'en sortir pour gagner la
finale
voilà exactement donc comme si on peut
suffire donc à voir ce qui se passe
alors bon parce que les biens sont quand
même très imprudent et donne la dame
même ce qui se passe prenant la dame
alors vous prendra effectivement ici bon
alors si on reprend le fou on a perdu on
a tout perdu
c'est très simple reprend le full
options pas l'idée n'en sait pas lire
ici il faut trouver autre chose
fou prend pions f cet échec au roi donc
là le roi est en échec la contre attaque
le cavalier progrès cinq autres otages
le fou et la case 17 donc le roi n'a
plus qu'une case la case de cette la
case hausse est alors là qu'est ce qu'on
se dit ou se dit le roi il a plu
beaucoup de cases il a plus que cette
case m6 alors si je peux le mettre en
échec et contrôler la casa fils en même
temps evil 5 ans la droite le roi serait
mal puisque le fou contrôler la case aux
6es l'a48 lecavalier contrôler ces deux
cases c'est vers le foot à vii et la caf
il suffit de ramener le cavalier sur la
case des cinq pour faire un math avec
une dame entière de monde on fait juste
un mat avec trois pièces mineurs tu as
eu superbement c'est un superbe match
puisque tout se passe au centre c'est
vraiment dans les grands principes de
l'ouverture donc ça ça démontre que le
clouage le clouage relatif donc la
cloche d'une dame aux mille existe mais
il faut faire attention si on n'est pas
obligé de ne pas bouger la pièce alors
que le camp de saint ambroix derrière on
est obligé ou pas c'est interdit par les
règles voile ça montre qu'il faut être
prudent
donc vous avez vu l'exemple de la
défense me dominique où le cavalier
était cloué de façon absolue ces terres
que c'est le roi qui était co est
derrière et ça donc c'était une source
de sécurité pour le compte louer alors
que l'ajustement c'est un clouage
totalement relatif puisque ça n'attaque
est que la dame c'est quand même
important mais ce n'est pas une garantie
de fiabilité puisque on le voit avec
cette combinaison va la revoir au
ralenti fou j'ai quatre cavaliers prend
pion aux 5 ou là là cavalier prend pion
aux 5 fu panda mme obligatoire sinon on
perd un pion fou preuve cet échec 3 au 7
et qui a aidé cinq échecs et mat
alors au vu du mat valait mieux prendre
le cavalier au vu de ma qu'il valait
mieux prendre le cahier bien
qu'évidemment serait dans une position
très délicate avec un pion - et aucune
case sortie mais enfin mieux vaut mieux
vaut à bayonne et wiba mieux vaut rien
du tout mieux vaut ne pas se faire mater
moins de sept coups puisque là c'est un
battant 7
donc ne vous perdre un pion que te faire
mater très très vite voilà je vais
retient exemple sur le cloud c'est une
belle conclusion sur le clouage donc on
a vu dans clé que j'ai absolument néons
ne peut plus bouger la pièce c'est la
tour où le fou qui
qui contrôle ce qui empêche la pièce de
bouger clause relative son coût par
exemple une pièce derrière lui une dame
dans ce cas la bombe effectivement il
faut faire attention que la pièce ne
peut pas sortir comme dans le cas du mat
de le gall où la pièce peut
effectivement sortir pour asséner un
math donc cinq lois relatifs
oui alors ce qu'on peut dire également
c'est qu'on peut clouer toutes les
pièces ont peu plus loin deux cavaliers
un fou une tour ou même il dame
c'est ce qu'on a vu avec l'exemple du
patte d'oie les coutures c4 donc toutes
les pièces peuvent être cloué toutes les
pièces peuvent louer sauf le cavalier
est effectivement on verra dans une
prochaine émission diagonale la leçon
les tout ce qui peut se passer entre
justement les attaques double les clous
âge et les autres telle tactique un peu
on verra comment tout ça peut
s'imbriquent et voilà c'est terminé donc
vous dire la prochaine fois
et